[MUSIC PLAYING]
RYAN MATSUMOTO:
Cloud Shell Editor
makes it easy for you
to write code directly
in your web browser and
deploy it to the cloud.
Powered by the Eclipse
Theia IDE Platform,
Cloud Shell Editor
provides a rich experience
that makes it easy for you
to debug your applications
before deploying to the cloud.
In this video, we'll
walk through an example
of how to run and debug a
local deployment of a Cloud Run
service.
Cloud Run makes
it easy to deploy
highly scalable containerized
applications on a fully
managed server-less platform.
But before you
deploy to Cloud Run,
you may want to run
your app locally
to simplify the
debugging process.
First, visit
ide.cloud.google.com
to launch the
Cloud Shell Editor.
On the status bar at the
bottom of your screen,
click Cloud Code.
From the Cloud Code menu,
click New Application,
and then select the
Cloud Run Application
for the type of sample
app we want to create.
After that, we'll get a
list of Cloud Run templates
to choose from.
Let's go with the
Node.js option.
Next, select a folder and
your Cloud Shell environment
to save your application
to, and give it a name.
If that looks good, click
Create New Application.
Cloud Shell Editor
clones the files
for your sample application from
GitHub into a new workspace.
You can see the list of files
in the Explorer panel located
on the left side of the screen.
Now let's go ahead and run
this application locally.
From the Cloud Code menu, click
Run on Cloud Run Emulator.
In the run debug on Cloud
Run Emulator dialogue,
you can choose your Builder
and adjust Build and Service
settings.
We'll leave everything as
their default values for now.
After defining your preferred
settings, click Run.
Right now, Cloud
Code is spinning up
an environment that emulates
Cloud Run's production
environment.
You can monitor the
progress of your application
in the output window.
You may need to click
Authorize to authorize
Cloud Shell to make Google
Cloud Platform API calls.
Once your app is built,
you can launch it
by hovering over the URL link
displayed in the output panel
and clicking Open Web Preview.
Congratulations.
If you see this page, that
means you've successfully
run your Cloud Run app locally.
Once your service
is running, there
are some other options you
can access from the Cloud Code
Status Bar.
You can open deployment
logs, open the service URL,
or turn watch mode on or off.
With watch mode,
Cloud Code continually
watch watches the file system
for changes to your files.
If changes are detected, it
will redeploy your application
so that your edits are
reflected in near real time.
Once you're done, you
can click the Stop button
to stop running your service.
Now that you've learned how to
develop locally with Cloud Run,
let's take a look at how you can
debug a Cloud Run application.
Click the Explorer
icon in the upper left
to display all the code files.
Let's double-click on
index.js to open it.
Lets go ahead and add some code
to the app's root directory.
We'll create two variables
and give them initial values.
A third variable will be set to
equal to sum of the first two
variables.
Finally, we'll increment
the first variable.
To add a break point, just
click in the editor margin
of the file you're debugging.
Once it's added, the break point
will appear as a red circle.
We'll go ahead and
add 5 break points,
starting with our first
line of extra code.
Now let's go ahead and
run our service locally
with the debugger
session attached.
From the Cloud Code menu, click
debug on Cloud Run Emulator.
Next, press Enter to confirm
that the application you
would like to debug can be
found in the listed directory.
Once you see the orange
bar at the bottom,
you are now in debug mode.
Launch the app by hovering
over the URL link displayed
in the output panel and
clicking Open Web Preview.
Now go back to the Cloud
Shell Editor window.
You'll see that the application
has paused at the first break
point, which is now a red
dot outlined in yellow.
In the debug sidebar, you can
manage the debugging session
with the debugging
action icons--
continue, step over, step into,
step out, restart, and stop.
The debug sidebar also
include sections for you
to view information about the
call stack, variable values,
and break points.
If we open up the
local variable section,
we see that our three variables
start out as undefined.
Let's go ahead and
click the Continue icon.
This advances us to
the next break point.
We see in the variable
section that the value of foo
has changed to 5.
If we keep clicking
Continue, the values
of the other variables
change as well.
We can also hover over
the variables in the code
to see what their
updated values are.
In this case, the
foo variable now
equals 6 because
it was incremented.
Once we get to the
last break point,
we can click Continue
to run through the rest
of the program.
Since there aren't
any errors, this
results in a
functional web page.
Once you're done, you
can click the Stop button
to stop your debugging session.
And there you have it.
Cloud Shell Editor provides
a full IDE experience
that makes it easy for
you to develop and debug
all kinds of applications
right from your web browser.
To get started with
Cloud Shell Editor,
visit ide.cloud.google.com.
Make sure to subscribe
to the channel,
and stay tuned for more
Cloud Shell Editor videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]